the website good hey guys i'm abby sharp
welcome to a special new series on
Abby's kitchen called the ridiculous now
this week's episode is brought to you by
the quintessential minefield of [ __ ]
goop oh yes
everyone's most hated entrepreneur miss
Gwyneth Paltrow has really done her due
diligence curating a beautiful list of
absolute pieces so today I want to share
a cute some of the most ridiculous items
you can buy on the GUP website that
definitely deserve a path let's do this
okay so first up on the Ridiculist is
this karela powder by sun potion so
you're supposed to drink some water with
a half a teaspoon of Corella algae as
part of your morning ritual of course
and apparently what it can do is
activate your brain nourish your organs
support digestive cycles that sounds
pretty legit and this is gonna cost you
about 35 bucks per hundred grams so
let's talk about Corella so karela is a
single-celled freshwater green algae
which sounds pretty healthy right off
the bat because we got green in there
and we all know green things are good
for us but a lot of people see this as a
superfood because it's got protein
it's got Omega threes iron I'm in b12
but see all the good stuff going on but
the research on karela when it comes to
health is definitely super early in
preliminary so early research suggests
that it might help with immunity
maybe preventing chronic diseases
possibly
in cholesterol however it's pretty much
impossible to know how much karela you
would actually need to consume in order
to see any of these benefits it's also
worth noting that while the FDA has
deemed karela as generally recognized as
safe a lot of people do complain that it
causes some digestive issues and kind of
upset stomach and all that kind of jazz
so it doesn't necessarily mean that
there's no side effects also we should
probably make it known that nutritional
supplements are not very well regulated
so it's really hard to know the
nutrition content of the karela because
it could depend on the species and the
processing so bottom line well there's
not a whole lot of harm in taking a
karela supplement for the $35 price tag
I'd say you can get a lot more bang for
your buck I mean come on you could get a
really good quality bottle of wine
there's a antioxidant there too so
that's probably what I be going for
number two on the ridiculous
is the amethyst bottle so this is 84
bucks for a bottle of Lord knows what
this is apparently it's an amethyst
crystal in a bottle that infuses the
water of positive energy and apparently
amethyst is thought to help transform
negative energy and enhance psychic
abilities mmm I am feeling like credit
card bill
really really big this month because
it's $84 you know I was at the beach
this summer and my kids had a rock in a
bucket of water and I should have sold
that for like 84 bucks and taking a tip
alamos Gweneth Paltrow is hat alright
let's talk about some of the research on
amethyst in the world of alternative
medicine Crystal's are king okay so
basically there's very little research
out there on crystals because who wants
to waste their their well-earned grant
money on this goal but one study in 2001
that was not actually published and I
wonder why found that the power of
crystals is in the eye of the beholder
in other words we're talking about the
placebo effect which in my opinion
applies to pretty much everything on the
GUP website so basically what they did
in this study was they gave everyone a
questionnaire and they found that the
individuals who had greater belief in
like spiritual abilities and psychic
abilities and things like that
experienced greater sensations from
using the crystals than the
non-believers hmm I wonder why so I
would say don't go drinking rock water
save your money
just drink regular water and you'll be
okay why would you spend any four bucks
on a [ __ ] rock on in water
bottom line drinking water it's a smart
thing to do drinking water that cost you
84 dollars because there's a rock inside
the bottle not so smart next and last
but definitely not least when it comes
to the ridiculous level paper crane
Apapa paper crane a pocket pathi carry
paper crane Apothecary psychic vampire
e-book
why is this hard to say because it
doesn't want me to say it cuz it's just
so bad paper crane Apothecary psychic of
Van parry van parry
I mean on upcoming and last but
definitely not least when it comes to a
ridiculous level paper crane Apothecary
psychic vampire repellent protection
mist that is a mouthful of crap alright
so this is the protective mist that uses
a combination of gem healing and deeply
aromatic healing essential oils so what
it can do apparently is banish bad vibes
and shield you from the people who may
be causing them I'm just not gonna say
what just came to my mind all right
ingredients include sonically tuned
water rose water grain alcohol
sea salt colloidal silver therapeutic
grade oils consisting of rosemary
juniper and lavender a unique and
complex blend of gem elixirs including
but not limited to black tourmaline
lapis lazuli rubra ruby labradorite
bloodstone aqua aura black onyx garnet
pyrite and new might Reiki sound waves
they've somehow gone sail waves in here
that's amazing moonlight loved reiki
charts charged crystals how the [ __ ] are
they getting love in this thing like
whose love is this like Gwyneth
Paltrow's love I don't want her love I
don't want it that is the last thing I
want the moonlight I be down with that
okay so like what could the research
possibly say on vampire repellent well
let me tell you folks not much so I
don't actually know what this vampire
repellent smells like partially because
a it cost $27 and I don't have 27
dollars to spend trying to get rid of
the vampires in my life and be
surprisingly
and disturbingly it's sold out somehow
but possibly it smells so bad it keeps
people away so I guess what I'll give
you is that essential oils can help
regulate moods in some way so
maybe that helps to banish the bad vibes
but vampires know bottom line the only
reason I would spend 27 dollars on this
stuff is to banish the bad vibes that
Gweneth Paltrow keeps hurling at us via
goop so I'm gonna give this one a hard-r
pass so guys I hope you enjoyed this
edition of the ridiculous if you did be
sure to give it the thumbs up
leave me a comment below with any
ridiculous things and products you have
seen on the Internet I would love to
hear about them don't forget to
subscribe to the channel and I will see
you next time on Abby's kitchen bye
[Music]